[Applause]
this is the moment the land gave way
people watch in disbelief
and within seconds dozens of homes are
buried underneath tons of mud and rock
the remote community springs in action
to rescue neighbors friends and family
while they wait for emergency services
to arrive
doctors and nurses from nearby districts
are already at the landslide zone the
minister of defense is arriving along
with the national institute of civil
defense and rescuers doctors and nurses
too we acted immediately as soon as we
heard of this incident
rain is thought to have caused the
landslide but the area high up in the
andes where miners live has always been
deemed unsafe building on riverbanks and
hillsides prone to landslides is common
in peru and often illegal
it's all part of systematic corruption a
country where on tuesday congress
approved the start of impeachment
proceedings against the president pedro
castillo in parliament denied opposition
accusations of corruption and bribing in
exchange for public projects
above the ideological and political
differences there are the interests of
the homeland and the future of our
citizens this is the moment to put an
end to the petty disputes and work for
great national objectives
soon after he wrote this message
reassuring the public that he'll be
visiting the landslide himself
but for a community that went through a
similar event in 2009 they are now
reliving a
nightmare as the number of missing loved
ones continue to rise
al jazeera